[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans auditions
publiques une heure un invité tous les
lundis soirs à 19h30 sur public c'est
naï LCP soyez donc les bienvenus notre
invité ce soir c'est Marc fenault
bonsoir à vous marchez merci d'être avec
nous ministres de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire la sécheresse
qui Séville les pesticides sur lesquels
vous avez plaisanter récemment au Sénat
mais qui sont un sujet majeur pour les
producteurs le bio en berne les prises
alimentaires en hausse la réforme des
retraites des décrets sont parus hier
est-ce un bras d'honneur aux manifestant
de demain vous le direz l'atmosphère à
l'Assemblée nationale est-elle
respirable Brigitte Boucher est un
traduit reviendront sur ses enjeux dans
quelques instants Vincent roux sur les
questions d'actualité Yves trèsart sur
la suite du quinquennat marcéno sans
majorité absolue êtes-vous condamné à
naviguer à vue Emmanuel Macron est-il
peut-il mener des réformes avez-vous la
réponse à cette question
évidemment pour la suite du mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron tout cela sont des
questions sur laquelle on va revenir je
voudrais quelques instants d'abord en
introduction revenir avec vous sur cette
divergence entre Elisabeth borne et
Emmanuel Macron sur la meilleure façon
de lutter contre le rassemblement
national pourquoi parce que la première
ministre avait estimé publiquement que
le parti de Marine Le Pen était
l'héritier de Pétain le président a
dilué en conseil des ministres la morale
en substance la morale n'est pas
efficace pour convaincre les électeurs
mais je le cite dans le texte on ne
combat pas l'extrême droite avec les
mots des années 90 sur le fond c'est une
question importante c'est une question
importante sur le fond quelle est la
bonne stratégie celle du président ou
celle de la première ministre ne me dit
pas les deux mon capitaine parce que les
deux ne sont pas les mêmes mais c'est
les deux ne répondent pas aux mêmes
questions
la première ministre pardon je vais vous
faire ma réponse quand même les deux ne
répondaient pas à la même question la
première ministre Elisabeth borne a
répondu à une question d'un de vos
confrères sur radiologie qui était de
dire est-ce que vous pensez
qu'historiquement le Front National et
l'héritier du front du rassemblement
national et l'héritier du Front national
lui-même fondé par un certain nombre de
gens qui étaient des héritiers de
pétains qui avaient été dans l'héritage
de Pétain et à cette question elle
répond oui comme tout le monde peut
répondre oui c'est un fait historique ce
faisant elle relie
historiquement c'est comme ça que le
fondateur du Front national c'était
Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est Jean-Marie Le
Pen Jean-Marie Le Pen il avait dans ses
équipes des gens qui étaient les
héritiers pour une part d'entre eux de
ça c'est dans les fondateurs dans les
mondes fondateurs il y a des gens qui
avaient été militants si je peux dire de
cette de cette cause là donc la première
ministre répond à cela qui est un fait
historique et qu'il faut jamais oublier
parce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que au fond finalement sur ces
questions là il faut jamais
penser que parce qu'on changerait
d'habits il y a pas derrière pour
certains en tout cas des gens qui se
réclameraient ou qui derrière aurait
cette philosophie là la deuxième
question c'est de savoir comment on
combat
non seulement les idées mais la
progression du rassemblement national
dans les dans les ions on est dans les
voies et là c'est la question de la
façon dont s'adresse aux électeurs ce
qui est une autre question et le
président de la République a eu raison
de rappeler que s'adresser aux électeurs
c'est pas quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs et
quel que soit l'endroit où il se situe
quel que soit leur vote ce n'est pas de
leur donner des leçons et ce n'est pas
ce qu'elle fait Elisabeth vous étiez au
Conseil alors en plus alors vous n'y
étiez pas j'étais en conseil de
l'agriculture à Bruxelles vous avez le
droit c'est votre métier mais simplement
évidemment que de faire fruité cette
admonestation d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'égard d'Elizabeth band c'était bien
pour souligner quand même qu'il y avait
une différence de la République je suis
coutumier des conseils des ministres ou
ce n'est pas le la présidence de la
République qui fuite c'est parfois des
gens qui sont autour de la table et qui
pensent qu'il faut fut futé moi j'ai
pour principe
de ne pas faire fuiter les débats et les
ce qui se dit au Conseil des ministres
c'est le lieu où on doit pouvoir dire
des choses
et sans que ce soit de nature publique
et donc je trouve que il y a aucun
intérêt à faire fuer ce genre de choses
donc je ne peux pas les propos tels qui
sont et deuxièmement sur le fond je vous
ai répondu il me semble que la question
fondamentale c'est d'essayer de
retrouver de l'apaisement dans le pays
on en reparlera tout à l'heure c'est la
question de répondre à ceux qui vont
parfois vers les votes populistes à
l'extrême gauche ou à l'extrême droite
et ce à qui faut répondre des sujets qui
sont les leurs cela dit Emmanuel Macron
qui dit comment qu'il faut lutter contre
le rassemblement national
avec un quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron le
rassemblement national n'a pas cessé de
monter donc en termes d'efficacité il
n'est pas le meilleur j'ai suffisamment
d'expérience politique ou d'ancienneté
politique depuis 84 le rassemblement
national il n'a jamais cessé d'augmenter
donc on doit tous se mettre en cause et
je pense que le sujet principal c'est le
sentiment que un en n'écoute pas ou sans
se on ne verbalise pas ce que vivent les
gens et le deuxième sujet c'est
d'essayer de résoudre les sujets et je
crois que c'est ce que nous essayons de
faire depuis 5 ans mais je prends un
seul exemple quand vous êtes sur la
question de l'hôpital qui a autant de
retard accumulés sur la question de la
médecine libérale François Beaune si
a-t-elle comme si prédécesseurs aussi
quand vous libérez le numerus clausus
vous avez des effets à 9 ans quand vous
décidez de mettre 9 milliards c'était
sous Jean Castex sur le Ségur de la
santé vous résonnez à 3 4 5 ou 6 ans et
donc il faut qu'on accepte aussi que
rétablir un certain nombre de choses en
particulier dans ce domaine par exemple
de la santé ça prend du temps et c'est
ça qu'il faut qu'on explicite aussi la
politique est un temps long et
supporte assez mal les chaînes
d'information continue ou la demande
continue Twitter alors quand même cette
petite coeur à la distance en tout cas
c'est comme ça qu'elle a été perçue
l'émetteur est toujours un peu
responsable de la perception des faits
évidemment à entraîner beaucoup de
commentaires je vous cite celui-là de
Alexis Corbière député la France
insoumise sur LCI il a estimé je vais le
dire en terme cru Emmanuel Macron est un
lâche il s'essuie sur les pieds de
madame borne ce qu'il a tort super bien
écoute humilié de comment dirais-je de
l'excès des propos il a un sur le fond
Tor et de
il n'est jamais avare de de mots qui
sont des mots qui sont disproportionnés
et qui ne relèvent pas du champ
politique me semble-t-il de Monsieur
Corbière comme les autres devraient
faire attention aux mots qu'il emploie
parce que c'est inexact sur le fond et
c'est une approprié sur la forme
comme ça c'est un jurieux bien sûr il
peut y avoir il est coutumé le fait que
le premier ministre la première ministre
le président de la République puisse
avoir des débats mais dire cela c'est un
défaut de vérité par ailleurs c'est des
mots qui sont des moins je précise
qu'Emmanuel Macron interrogé il y a
quelques minutes au Mont-Saint-Michel à
l'occasion d'un déplacement sur cette
querelle alors supposée je le dis quand
même parce que il répond que c'est du
clapotis du clapotis pardon et que ce
sont des bulles de savon sur lesquels il
ne veut pas
se s'arrêter
de fond je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
parce que je veux dire mais commenter
des phrases auxquelles personne
n'insister essayez de nourrir
d'écureuils il me semble qu'on ressent
effectivement plutôt du clapotis que du
fond le remaniement ça n'est pas du
clapotis ça concerne ça concerne et tout
à l'heure extraire vous interrogera sur
le maintien ou non d'Elizabeth borne à
Matignon dans les semaines
pré-remaniement pour remaniement
est prévenu de la façon dont vous allez
l'aborder je vous présente mais vous les
connaissez Brigitte boucher voilà
pour le Sénat et évidemment on commence
par la grande affaire des retraites elle
revient dans la rue demain exactement
nouvelle journée de mobilisation donc
demain l'intersyndicale ne désarme pas
Sophie Binet la secrétaire général de la
CGT juge que je la cite rien n'est écrit
d'avant ça l'estime que les suites
dépendants du niveau de mobilisation
est-ce qu'elle a tort
je pense pas que les choses doivent se
dire comme ça d'abord faut toujours
respecter les mobilisations et vous
m'avez jamais entendu dire autre chose
qu'il faut écouter ce qui peut se dire
dans la rue on verra ce qui est l'état
de la mobilisation demain à la sujet
désormais c'est de faire en sorte que la
réforme qui a été votée puisse dérouler
vous on viendra peut-être sur les
décrets d'application elle a été votée
dans la temporalité de l'année 2023 pour
qu'elle puisse s'appliquer dès le
premier septembre pour un certain nombre
de mesures il est pas illogique que nous
déroulions les choses ça n'empêche pas
qu'il faut qu'on continue le travail
d'explication la mobilisation de demain
elle peut changer les choses pour vous
selon son importance
il faut pas l'écouter mais la nécessité
pardon est-ce qu'il y a besoin de de
réformer le système de retraite
aujourd'hui il y a six mois où il y a 12
mois la vérité c'est oui c'est à dire
que la mobilisation ne change rien il
n'y a pas de retrait envisageable de la
réforme on peut pas en permanence
gouverner c'est pas la question du
gouverner ça n'est pas simplement la
question d'être populaire la question de
gouverner c'est qu'est-ce qu'on a de
quoi on a besoin comme réforme
responsabilité pour le pays on part on
passe notre temps on va en parler
demain on passe notre temps
à parler de souveraineté la première des
souverainetés c'est de ne pas dépendre
des autres pour se financer et donc
d'avoir de temps vers des équilibres
budgétaires cette réforme elle vise à ça
avec un certain nombre d'autres mesures
qui viennent aussi améliorer la
situation qui est celle d'aujourd'hui de
ceux qui vont partir à la retraite et
donc qu'on puisse écouter les
manifestants qu'on puisse écouter la
colère mais qu'on puisse dire aussi sans
être insultant l'endroit de personnes
qu'on pense que cette réforme est
nécessaire c'est pour ça qu'on l'a voté
y compris
au risque de l'impopularité avec le
chemin que nous avons fait je pense que
il faut que cette réforme désormais
puisse se dire alors justement les deux
premiers décrets d'application sont
parus hier au Journal officiel avec
notamment la mesure la plus controversée
contre laquelle se battent les
manifestants celles qui concerne le
report de l'âge légal est-ce que ce
n'est pas provocateur en cette semaine
de mobilisation dans la rue à
l'Assemblée nationale le texte il a été
voté il est passé sous les fourches
collines si vous me permettez
l'expression du Conseil constitutionnel
et au motif qu'il y avait un impact
budgétaire en 2023 il a été mis dans un
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificative et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça en partie que le
Conseil constitutionnel va valider
puisqu'il y avait des mesures ça rentre
en vidéo puisse se mettre en oeuvre dès
le mois de septembre nous sommes le 5
juin n'est pas illogique que nous
fassions en sorte sauf à avoir
mentielle
vous l'auriez fait à la fin de la
semaine après le parcourses
avant une mobilisation
avec lequel j'aborde toujours ces sujets
là il y a aucune offense qui est faite à
personne simplement les décrets
d'application il y a une temporalité il
y a des choses à préparer on est au mois
de juin il faut que ça soit promotrice
c'est pas une offense sur un texte qui
est voté qui est voté qui est
définitivement
le texte celui-là il est définitivement
voté donc personne n'a jamais été voté
le plus puissant qu'il soit c'est une
notion de censure parce qu'il y a une
notion de censure sur le texte
parce qu'il y a encore un épisode par le
monde il y a disposition de loi du
groupe liotte qui vise à abroger la
réforme des retraites qui va être
discuté jeudi dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a cet article
1 avec un amendement de suppression qui
a été adopté
qui a été voté adopté en commission et
qui vise donc à supprimer le retour à la
retraite à 62 ans
le groupe liote a déposé un amendement
de rétablissement c'est-à-dire pour que
on puisse revenir à la retraite à 62 ans
est-ce que vous souhaitez que la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
fasse jouer l'article 40 de la
Constitution et juge cet amendement il
recevable sur le plan financier moi je
n'ai pas d'injonction à donner à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
été ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement simplement je dis ce que j'ai
dit il y a six semaines c'est que
manifestement l'article 1 il vient il
vient ajouter une charge complémentaire
au budget de l'État ou une perte de
recettes ça dépend des façons dont on
peut le lire et que l'article 40 prévoit
que dans ce cas-là c'est irrecevable
vous n'êtes pas sûr qu'il y a elle brand
Pivet brandit
vous n'êtes pas sûr à ce stade je n'ai
pas dit ça du tout je dis juste que je
ne viens pas donner des leçons on a
l'impression quand même que le
gouvernement a tortu le bras à la
présidente
donc vous me trouverez pas sur le
terrain d'aller donner une injonction au
Parlement parce que c'est la règle il
faut qu'on essaie de respecter vous avez
reçu des agents ils sont peut-être quand
vous étiez non non j'ai jamais reçu
l'injonction j'ai jamais reçu
l'injonction j'ai essayé de convaincre
parfois sur certains sujets j'ai essayé
de trouver des équilibres pour que des
textes puissent passer de faire qui est
un dialogue entre la majorité et le
gouvernement parfois entre la majorité
l'opposition et le gouvernement ça c'est
le boulot du
mrpable si vous lisez la Constitution
structurellement si ce texte est évoqué
avec un article 1 comme il est rédigé et
qu'il était au Conseil constitutionnel
le Conseil constitutionnel le sussant le
censurer un seul motif le motif de
l'application de l'article 40 alors vous
avez peut-être lu le journal Le Monde il
y a une tribune de Charles de Courson
donc qui est député du groupe lot et qui
porte cette proposition de loi qui est
soutenue par l'ensemble de la nuque et
dans cette tribune il y a écrit que la
jurisprudence veut que l'examen se fasse
sur la base de référence la plus
favorable à l'initiative par le monde
est-ce que vous reconnaissez que cette
irrecevabilité de cette proposition de
loi elle n'est pas dans la pratique
parlementaire écoutez l'article 40 il a
déjà été invoqué sur un certain nombre
beaucoup moins sur des propositions
qui a supprimé l'article il y a un
amendement qui relève de l'article 40
voilà c'est tout de balayer cette
position là je vais vous dire il y a
quelque chose sur le fond au-delà
je vous lis le texte parce que c'est
important il est de jurisprudence
constante que cet examen se fasse sur la
base de référence la plus favorable à
l'initiative parlementaire très bien
alors il est je rappelle que Charles de
Courson disait pour le QG pour lequel
j'ai plutôt grand respect parce que je
l'ai connu dans d'autres temps et en
d'autres lieux et servant d'autres
causes à la vérité y compris des
équilibres budgétaires mais peu importe
on a le droit de changer dans sa vie il
nous expliquait aussi que par nature le
Conseil constitutionnel allait censurer
le texte parce qu'il y avait des tas de
motifs de censure il a été même à
l'initiative de la de de
renvoi aux conseils constitutionnel du
texte avec d'autres le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas jugé donc
laissons les constitutionnalistes
attendez laissons les
constitutionnaliser et ce n'est pas la
lecture que je fais je suis pas sûr
Charles de Courson puisse avoir une
lecture qui puisse s'opposer
il n'est pas là
parlementaires par leur vote et c'est le
Conseil constitutionnel ou la
Constitution en tant que tel par parce
qu'elle propose et ce qu'elle dit y
compris dans la jurisprudence cette
exprimé et sur le fond on voit bien
qu'il y a un sujet parce que la question
qui est posée par ailleurs les
initiatives vous le savez très bien il
faut qu'on prenne souvent
des niches parlementaires en permanence
qui viennent rajouter 15 milliards 20
milliards 30 milliards à la fin c'est
collectivement les responsabilité qui
règne parce que si le sujet suffit juste
de dire j'augmente la taxe sur les tabac
d'abord je lis à ceux qui sont
consommateurs de tabac ce que je ne
conseille pas mais le on dit quelque
chose qui est faux aux Français et la
seule question qui a posé me semble-t-il
y compris à Charles de Courson c'est
comment on équilibre le système de
retraite simplement ce que vous possédez
la drogation vous n'auriez pas préféré
qu'il y ait un vote au moins un seul
vote sur tout le parcours parlementaire
de cette réforme des retraites alors
effectivement il aurait pu être
défavorable pour le gouvernement mais au
moins le Parlement aurait pu mais ça
n'aurait pas été finalement plus
ce que je regrette c'est que l'esprit de
responsabilité est échapper un certain
nombre de gens je parle pas à des gens
de la nups pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux qui qui courent derrière la
dépense sans avoir la moindre conscience
de ce que ça peut produire pour les
Français parce que si vous n'êtes pas
capable de rembourser votre dette c'est
pas les plus riches qui sont les plus
pénalisés c'est les plus pauvres quand
vous regardez ce qui s'est passé dans
les pays qui ont fait défaut sur leur
dette ou qui ont eu des taux d'intérêt
contre montrés ça n'a jamais été les
plus riches qui ont été pénalisés ça a
toujours été les plus pauvres et donc
j'aurais plutôt espérer qu'on ait un
esprit de responsabilité ceci dit je
considère que il y a eu 49-3 c'est une
procédure parlementaire et il y a eu un
vote sur le 49 alors on continue à
parler quand même Conseil
constitutionnel et réforme des retraites
parce que le Groupe liote Bertrand
pencher a annoncé qu'il saisirait le
Conseil constitutionnel parce qu'il n'y
a pas eu de justement de vote sur la
réforme des retraites est-ce que c'est
quand même quelque chose que que vous
craignez déjà été saisi le Conseil
constitutionnel le Conseil
constitutionnel a rendu son avis sur la
réforme des retraites y compris sur le
fond est-ce que c'est un texte dans
l'application ça revient à nos décrets
et bien pour 2023 il a censuré un
certain nombre de mesures considérant
qu'il ne devait pas être dans ce texte
il a été dans son rôle et Conseil
constitutionnel a jugé sur la procédure
alors je veux bien qu'en permanence on
essaie de refaire les débats et les
matchs mais ce pays a besoin de
stabilité de cap et je pense pas qu'on
sert cette cause là
je trouve que le débat parlementaire
était long et puis par ailleurs pardon
les mêmes qui nous expliquaient que 15
jours ou 3 semaines n'était pas
suffisant pour se traiter de ce sujet
éminent des retraites on a quand même
fait plus de 15 jours de débat à
l'Assemblée nationale beaucoup d'heures
un temps aussi significatif au Sénat
vient de vous expliquer qu'en une
journée on peut traiter la question de
la réforme
c'est l'irresponsabilité c'est je
supprime je change rien et après on
verra ben non quand on est responsable
public on doit aussi trouver les
solutions pour équilibrer le système
c'est pas ce qu'on a sous les yeux on
gagnerait tous être responsable je vous
assure que dans ce pays on gagnerait
tous être responsable même si c'est
parfois avec la charge de la popularité
alors la sécheresse oui alors après une
année de sécheresse un peu hors norme il
a récemment plu est-ce que cette pluie à
améliorer la situation est-ce que les
nappes phréatiques se sont remplies ou
est-ce que la situation est encore dans
un dans une situation un peu
catastrophique aujourd'hui
un quart d'heure c'est d'abord c'est
assez disparate globalement il a plutôt
moi de janvier plutôt plus vieux février
très sec mars avril plutôt pluvieux et
en mai plutôt sur le sud pour le coup
qui était notre sujet de préoccupation
plutôt de la pluie ça ne fera pas
remonter le niveau des nappes simplement
ça empêche parce que le niveau des
nappes les nappes se remplissent à
l'automne à partir du mois d'octobre
jusqu'au mois de février mars ou plus
tard on dit début avril pour ce qui est
des nappes profondes en particulier où
les autres nappes donc ça ne fera pas
remonter le niveau des nappes en
revanche ça permet d'éviter d'avoir
recours à l'irrigation d'avoir des
tensions sur l'alimentation en eau
potable et donc ça permet dans certains
territoires mais ne faisons pas
d'homogénéité parce que je pense en vous
parlant à la situation du bassin
Méditerrané en particulier
Pyrénées-Orientales Aude ou héros ou la
pluie qui tombe n'est pas suffisante
aujourd'hui pour couvrir le besoin et où
les agriculteurs en particulier mais
d'autres aussi sont dans des situations
de très grandes fragilité quels sont les
départs combien de départements qui sont
touchés en fait aujourd'hui alors après
il y en a qui sont en vigilance mais
c'est un process normal que de mettre en
vigilance je reviens de la Gironde et
différentes ou les départements sont en
situation de vigilance vigilance ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on essaie de
de modérer de mettre en vigilance tout
le monde sur les sur les usages de l'eau
mais on n'est pas encore en situation de
crise ou de crise exceptionnelle et donc
il y a 5 6 départements qui se font
l'objet d'une attention particulière sur
le bassin méditerranéen il y en a un peu
plus qui sont en situation de vigilance
mais on va pas découvrir aujourd'hui que
chaque année les préfets procède à des
situations de vigilance et crise le
sujet c'est à la fois de gérer cette
crise là et en particulier les quatre
quelques départements qui sont très
durement touchés j'étais l'autre jour
chez un viticulteur
responsable des vignerons indépendants à
Fitou dans l'Aude il était tombé 95 mm
en un an en 13 mois sans irrigation
possible 95 mm en un an c'est la vigne
elle-même qui risque de disparaître sur
des sur des vignes et donc là on a
quelque chose à regarder de ce qu'on
peut faire tout de suite et puis le
sujet principal c'est de regarder dans
le long terme quels sont les systèmes
qu'on va rendre les plus résilients
possibles pour faire face à des épisodes
de sécheresse ou d'inondations
d'ailleurs en tout cas nous arithmique
climatique qui va rendre l'agriculture
plus fragile si on parle des
conséquences sur les particuliers par
exemple est-ce que dans le département
des Pyrénées-Orientales par exemple il y
a plus de piscine hors sol depuis le 10
mai c'est interdit est-ce que ça va se
poursuivre s'étendre à d'autres
départements dans les Pyrénées en
fonction de ces Christophe encore des
semaines tous l'été
j'ai du mal à répondre à cette question
là parce que je ne sais pas la météo là
de 15 jours si il tombe 100 mm alors on
annonce plutôt encore de l'eau
la semaine prochaine ou les 15 jours qui
viennent au sud je répète ça va pas
remplir les nappes ça évitera et ça
permettra de retrouver quelques étiages
dans les cours d'eau mais on a un été
difficile à passer sur ces régions là et
sur les autres il faut quand même qu'on
ait une pluviométrie désormais c'est
dans le Nord qui manque mon manque d'eau
il y a trois semaines on pouvait pas
planter c'est quoi le mauvaise météo
vérité c'est une mauvaise météo c'est
une météo qui dure trop longtemps c'est
trop de secs trop d'eau etc donc on a
besoin de raisonner sur le court terme à
des mesures comme celles qu'on fait sur
les piscines que tout le monde doit être
appelé à faire son effort il était
incompréhensible que on dise vous
agriculteurs des Pyrénées-Orientales
vous devez faire un effort sur
l'irrigation parfois avec des
interdictions sèches
et puis qu'on dise on continue à remplir
les piscines pour nos loisirs il faut
que chacun fasse sa part de l'effort et
je pense que c'est vous voyez bien avec
la façon dont je le dis il faut arrêter
de jeter de montrer du doigt les uns les
autres je ne jette pas le mets pas le
doigt sur ceux qui ont des piscines ou
des piscines gonflables ou les campings
de telle ou tel endroit qui ont besoin
qui ont utilisé l'eau ni les
agriculteurs faut juste que chacun en
raison dise je dois faire ma part c'est
comme ça qu'on essaiera de mieux
anticiper les situations qu'on connaît
alors on va parler également pesticides
marques feno il y a une séquence qui a
été tournée au Sénat par le média vakita
qui fait le tour des réseaux sociaux on
va la regarder
avec des gens qui sont la police de la
pensée et avec lesquels en réponse à une
ironie si aucun d'entre nous autour de
cette table n'a eu d'ironie sur tel ou
tel sujet non je lui fais pas mais pas
vis-à-vis des gens qui mangent il y a
des règles dans la communication
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça
dure mais c'est la loi et donc c'est
simplement une phrase sortie de son
contexte qui est adressé à d'autres
journalistes sur le temps d'ironie parce
que vous avez posé des questions
ironiques en début et en fait du
journaliste
vous dites que vous êtes pour la
réduction d'utilisation
j'en ai sur ce chemin là qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ceux qui vous disent que
vous êtes un défenseur des pesticides
entre et bien la position que vous avez
eu sur les néonicotinoïdes vous avez
voulu bien les reports bon bien sûr il y
a eu un moment ça n'a plus été possible
et ensuite sur le S met de la chlore où
vous vouliez aller contre la vie de
l'ancêtre qu'est-ce que vous répondez le
problème dans ce sujet là c'est qu'on
est dans la caricature jamais vous
m'avez entendu dire quand il y a eu la
décision de l'Europe sur les néonicotino
j'ai dit c'est terminé faut qu'on trouve
des alternatives et qu'on trouve des
sujets donc ne venons pas se faire des
vagues
et que je disais alors pardon je disais
une chose qui était simple je disais
est-ce qu'on a des alternatives
aujourd'hui généralisables la réponse
est non on est sur un bon chemin et donc
on a besoin de la 3e année dérogation
parce que c'était ce qui avait été voté
dans la loi c'était l'engagement qu'on
avait pris collectivement il y a une
décision de la Cour de justice je
l'applique et je n'y dérange pas et
quand au sujet du S métaux d'accord
c'est marrant comme on n'arrive pas à
dire des choses assez une seconde vous
savez que tout à l'heure et vous avez
accepté le principe du débat avec un
sénateur qui va socialiste qui va vous
interroger longuement sur les pesticides
on a encore une question au moins à vous
poser Brigitte
alors on va parler du bio du coup on va
passer au bio sans pesticides les
conclusions de l'Agence Bio la semaine
dernière montrait une baisse de 6% des
ventes qui est quand même assez
important vous avez présenté un plan à
200 millions d'euros est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que c'est suffisant
pour une filière qui est très mal en
point on a plusieurs sujets on a une
baisse de consommation qui est liée à la
fois l'inflation avec un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens qui ne peuvent plus
accéder donc une baisse en gamme en fait
certains et en gamme de prix notamment
d'un certain nombre de produits on a
deux volets une aide d'urgence de 60
millions qui vient se rajouter au 10
millions qui avait été indiqué déjà par
la première ministre et deux ce qu'il
faut c'est qu'on soutienne la demande le
sujet n'est plus l'offre je rappelle
qu'on a doublé les surfaces attendez
qu'on a doublé les surfaces en
agriculture biologique sous le
quinquennat précédent d'Emmanuel Macron
donc je veux bien que tous ces gens-là
viennent nous donner des leçons mais
nous nous avançons qu'on a donné un
objectif de passer de 10% si quelqu'un
aujourd'hui à 18% des surfaces
vous ne créez pas le débouché à coup de
centaines de millions de milliards pour
créer du débouché il faut qu'on fasse ce
que je ces dialogues qu'on aura avec
l'Agence Bio qui dépend de l'état c'est
une agence de l'État c'est de faire en
sorte qu'on ait une communication qui
soit plus proactive pour montrer
l'intérêt du bio et y compris ce qu'on
n'a pas vu à l'époque parce que la
baisse du bio la consommation de bio est
date de la covid pourquoi parce que sous
covid on a beaucoup développé les uns et
les autres d'ailleurs les circuits
courts les circuits de proximité bio ou
conventionnelles et donc on a besoin de
si vous permettez c'est que cette
sécrétion de redire en quoi le bio
lui-même est un produit de proximité
assez proximité est-ce qu'il faut pas
mettre de l'argent des aides
alimentaires
c'est pas forcément une question de de
c'est une question de prix pour un
certain nombre de Français qui ont pas
les moyens c'est une question d'image
collective qu'on doit porter le bio
c'est pas forcément plus cher ça dépend
ça dépend des catégories c'est pas
forcément plus cher deuxièmement il faut
que la grande distribution pourquoi sur
les produits bio la marge produite par
l'agrand distribution est plus grande
que sur les produits conventionnels
c'est une bonne question parce qu'après
tout si on veut soutenir on devrait
faire la même marche parce qu'une tomate
bio une tomate conventionnelle pourquoi
la marge est plus importante sur le bio
parce que on s'est mis dans la tête que
c'était un produit qui était adressé qui
a des gens qui avaient les moyens
et donc c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire ce
qu'il faut dire c'est à la fois
l'intérêt qu'il y a à développer le bio
en France il y a d'autres modèles mais
le bio est un modèle intéressant et le
deuxième sujet c'est d'essayer de
stimuler la demande en essayant
d'expliquer ce que c'est et donc on le
fait il faut que l'État soit exemplaire
soit 60 ou 70 millions d'aide d'urgence
et deuxième élément pardon juste
là-dessus parce que c'est important
c'est de stimuler la demande par la
commande publique dans les camps
aux autres déjà faut que l'État applique
dans ses propres cantines dans sa propre
restauration la loi
egalimat
au niveau national on est à 7% sur le
bio donc on doit atteindre les 20 mais
là
c'est ce que je vous dis c'est à peu
près dans la moyenne nationale et donc
on a
essayons de moi je ne fais pas le son à
personne c'est compliqué parce que il
faut trouver que les prestataires le
fassent et donc on a besoin nous au
niveau de l'état de faire cet effort
puis après sans donner l'accent aux
collectivités locales que c'est un effet
d'entraînement sur les collectivités
locales parce que les 120 millions de
demandes supplémentaires qu'on met sur
la table pour la commande publique c'est
la commande publique de l'État mais
après il y a tout le reste de la
commande publique qui peut aussi
stimuler le bio il faut stimuler la
consommation bio c'est comme ça qu'on
s'en sortira merci beaucoup Brigitte et
Ethan dans un instant évidemment ifthrée
avant de nous rejoindre mais d'abord on
rejoint en direct du Figaro live Vincent
roux bonsoir Vincent
est-ce que vous êtes là Vincent bonsoir
Elisabeth bonsoir à vous monsieur le
ministre Vincent normalement apparaît là
mais non là aujourd'hui voilà le voilà
bonjour bonsoir à vous Vincent votre
question au ministre
bonsoir Marc fenou je voulais qu'on
revienne sur la note de Standard and
port donc qui est de AA et perspective
négative est-ce que il faut s'en
satisfaire comme l'a fait Jean René
Cazeneuve le rapporteur du budget
est-ce qu'il y a pas encore quand même
des mesures à prendre pour améliorer
cette note
je sais pas ce qui a dit Jean René
Cazeneuve que je connais bien qui est
très vigilant sur les questions
budgétaires c'est plutôt satisfaisant
qu'on est notre stable est-ce que ça
veut dire attendez
satisfait de cette de cette on peut à la
fois dire que la note c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'on sait les
effets que ça peut avoir sur les taux
mais ça ne veut pas dire nous allons
avoir des réunions avec tous les sous
l'autorité de la première ministre pour
regarder comment on tient notre budget
dans un cadre budgétaire la réforme des
retraites elle participe d'ailleurs la
Standard zen pour je le dis
d'une tendance et d'une volonté
collective que nous avons de rétablir
les finances publiques de ce pays donc
c'est satisfaisant à tenter et sur le
temps long ça nécessite plutôt de
poursuivre l'effort plutôt que de le
relâcher et donc on a besoin de
continuer cet effort de déficience de la
de la de la dépense publique et de
réduction là où on peut de la dépense
publique
vous êtes satisfait Vincent alors où il
faut il faut concentrer cet effort
alors on est dans un travail qu'on fait
en interministériel de regarder il y a
un certain nombre de dépenses parfois
des dépenses fiscales qu'on ne peut
réorienter vers la vers des mesures en
termes de transition et écologique c'est
plutôt là qu'il faut le faire mais par
ailleurs il faut aussi assumer ce qui a
toujours assumé le président de la
République on peut pas à la fois dire ça
on a le droit de programmation militaire
on a une loi de programmation de
sécurité intérieure on a des besoins en
termes d'éducation nationale et donc il
faut stimuler par une évolution de
parfois de la fiscalité et puis parfois
faut regarder dans chaque c'est pas moi
qui vais faire cet exercice là je le
fais pour ce qui est du ministère de la
Culture actuellement de regarder là où
on peut avoir une défense une dépense
qui soit plus efficiente mais référence
de la réforme de l'assurance chômage
réforme des retraites le plus haut taux
d'emploi c'est une façon aussi de créer
de la richesse et de lutter contre le
déficit public merci beaucoup Vincent à
tout à l'heure bien sûr Yves très hard
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro bonsoir C'est à vous bonsoir
Elizabeth bonsoir Marc fenault alors ça
vous empêche était quand même assez
compliqué pendant cet hiver avec la
réforme des retraites et on sent que le
Président de la République avait
reconquérir le cœur de l'opinion
publique est-ce que si une bonne façon
de le faire non pas en parlant du
quotidien des françaises qui fait quand
même un peu mais beaucoup d'histoires on
voit que là il est dans une séquence
mémorielle aujourd'hui des en train de
célébrer les 1000 ans de la l'abbaye de
Mont-Saint-Michel au mois de mai il a il
a rendu hommage à Jean Moulin et au
Conseil national de la Résistance demain
il va sur les plages du débarquement il
y aura aussi un hommage aux réseaux
Manoukian à l'occasion du 18 juin
vous croyez qu'en parlant aux Français
de la grandeur de la France de
l'histoire et de la mémoire on
accroche leur
leur vote je crois pas que ce soit la
volonté du Président de la République
d'abord les faits historiques s'imposent
à nous les 1000 ans du Mont-Saint-Michel
tomba pardon oui mais on n'est pas
obligé de célébrons on peut considérer
qu'il y a quelque chose dans la
conscient objectif en France la Tour
Eiffel le Mont-Saint-Michel
c'est pour ça que je suis très méfiant à
cet endroit de ceux qui veulent en
permanence revisiter l'histoire et nous
dire que c'est nous ne vont pas être
fiers faut être fier attendez une
question je vous ai il faut être fier ça
fait partie c'est la réponse à la cancel
culture et oui
on est le président de la République ils
nous autres qui sommes au gouvernement
et la majorité passe pas son temps et
essayer de répondre à la conception mais
que nous fassions notre chemin sur ce
qu'on pense être des données historiques
ce qui a été fait sur le Conseil
National de la Résistance c'est parce
que nous célébrions les 80 ans donc ça
c'est l'effet historiques mais pour
avoir vu le président de la République
discuter avec lui encore qu'on nous
étions dans le Gard par exemple sur les
feux de forêt et sur la question des
moyens pour les feux de forêt c'est un
exemple c'est un exemple très concret je
peux vous garantir que dans le dialogue
que nous avons eu on a parlé plutôt de
sujets concrets sujets agricoles entre
autres si j'ai environnementaux plutôt
que mais on peut à la fois célébrer la
France dans ce cas-là dans son histoire
profonde son histoire ça grandes
histoire et en même temps s'occuper des
Français ce n'est pas antinomique et
voyez bien que sur beaucoup de sujets
sur les questions des retraites ils
étaient exprimés à plusieurs reprises il
y avait aujourd'hui un conseil national
de la refondation sur les questions de
logement avec un certain nombre de
mesures vous voyez bien qu'on peut faire
les deux sans se venir à chaque fois
dire alors quand il est sur un sujet
très concret on dit s'occupe de tout
quand il est à s'occuper de l'un et des
sujets historiques qu'on dit il fait
trop d'histoires enfin il faudrait qu'on
essaie de simplement regarder de façon
tranquille le fait qu'il y a des moments
historiques qui sont assez livrés parce
que c'est l'histoire de France et puis
ça m'empêche pas de s'occuper si j'étais
français parce que les dates historiques
on les connaît dites moi ce que vous
voulez savoir on voudrait savoir quand
est-ce qu'on commence cette réforme de
l'immigration ce texte de loi qui nous
est promis à intervalles réguliers dont
on connaît assez mal les contours avec
une première ministre qui a pas l'air
très emballé par le dossier mais ça on
voudrait savoir par exemple
le ministre de l'Intérieur le ministre
du Travail Gérald Darmanin et Olivier du
soft travail à regarder comme on peut
avoir un texte qui puisse susciter
l'adhésion la plus large possible on
peut pas à la fois se dire vous ne
voulez pas écouter vous ne voulez pas
travailler avec les oppositions avec
votre majorité donc quand on estimera
qu'on a quelque chose qui est un point
d'équilibre intéressant à ce moment-là
il pourrait y avoir le texte mais votre
problème c'est l'opposition à
l'intérieur de la majorité non d'accord
c'est pas une opposition on peut avoir
des débats donc enfin moi je les dis
quand j'étais relation avec le Parlement
il faut qu'on accepte dans une majorité
mais aussi avec les oppositions de la
majorité relative qu'on puisse avoir des
débats essayer de trouver un chemin sur
ce sujet là c'est un sujet suffisamment
sérieux sur lequel tout le monde bute
depuis 40 ans pour qu'on essaie de se
dire est-ce que collectivement on peut
pas se dire voilà le train qu'on veut
avoir sans avoir en permanence des
virages d'une d'un quinquennat ou d'un
quinquennat à l'autre est-ce que vous
allez est-ce que vous allez reprendre
certaines propositions de parties les
républicains notamment sur un changement
de la Constitution ou
sur d'autres dispositions qui vous
paraissent qui pourraient vous paraître
acceptable j'ai déjà beaucoup de sujets
donc mais je vais vous
dire
360 degrés qu'on essaie de regarder avec
les républicains quels sont les points
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a été fait aussi
dans le dialogue qui peut y avoir avec
le Sénat ces sujets là après il y a des
principes de base c'est n'essayons pas
d'engager des sujets constitutionnels
quand on sait qu'on a pas de majorité
constitutionnelle n'essayons pas nous
l'opposition elle est non plus essayons
de ne pas nous affranchir des traités
européens c'est mieux moi je pense quand
on a des traités aussi sensibles aussi
difficiles sur lesquels tout le monde
bute depuis des années d'essayer de
trouver des chemins qui sont des chemins
crédibles parce que sinon ceux qui nous
regardent et qui nous entendent ils
disent à chaque fois ils font du
déclammatoire à chaque fois ils
promettent et à la fin on recule donc le
mieux c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte
qu'on essaye avec des LR avec d'autres
parce qu'il y a pas collé LR il y a
aussi peut-être sur la frange plus à
gauche de l'acide de l'hémicycle des
gens qui peuvent en conscience
considérer que nous sommes en situation
d'échec à la fois contre pour lutter
contre les fluides les flux migratoires
de clandestins
vous le dites ça le gouvernement est en
situation d'échec vous dites-le dire
mais nous sommes
collectivement je vois bien la
reformulation voulait me faire faire
mais je connais trop l'exercice j'ai pas
j'ai dit collectivement
l'objectif que nous assignons tous c'est
une difficulté la reconduite à la
frontière est un sujet complexe
l'intégration est un sujet complexe
alors il faut qu'on essaie de travailler
d'améliorer les choses est-ce que vous
si vous pensez que c'était parfois on
ferait pas de texte ministre de
l'Agriculture parce que vous êtes
concernés est-ce que dans les métiers en
tension il faut régulariser mais alors
c'est pas forcément seulement c'est ça
qui divise aussi mais c'est pas
forcément des sujets de régularisation
c'est aussi le faire en sorte que quand
on fait venir par exemple de la main
d'oeuvre de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée parfois c'est beaucoup de
la main d'oeuvre européenne donc c'est
un sujet d'une autre nature mais quand
on est sur des des travailleurs
saisonniers qui viennent de l'autre côté
de la Méditerranée principalement de
qui sont pas dans l'espace Schengen de
faire en sorte qu'il soit bien ils
viennent bien pour le travail que ça ne
vient pas comment dirais alimenter le
comment dirais un flux migratoire qui
sont un flux migratoire de gens qui
s'installent dans la clandestinité si je
peux d'accord voilà alors est-ce que
vous seriez pas en mesure peut-être de
légiférer sur ce terrain avec un
gouvernement peut-être davantage
homogène avec une un premier ministre ou
une première ministre qui soit davantage
en phase avec le président de la
République sur ce sujet mais je ne vois
pas qu'il y ait pas de distorsion de
face en tout cas j'ai pas assisté je ne
crois pas que ce soit sujet là ce sujet
c'est trouver un point d'équilibre alors
je vois bien pour vous voulez me faire
rentrer dans
le moment joyeux que j'ai vécu plusieurs
fois qui est le moment où on spécule
parce que c'est souvent c'est souvent un
sujet
est souvent propice il nous a dit 100
jours
il a pas dit alors on a tous une
imagination galopante il a pas dit dans
son jour on change de gouvernement on
change les jours
de déployer une feuille de route sur un
certain nombre de sujets mais pas sur
l'immigration donc on est en train
d'essayer de trouver les conditions on
est en train d'essayer de trouver les
conditions de d'un chemin sur
l'immigration mais ce qu'on fait sur les
questions de logement ce qu'on fait sur
les questions de carbone les transitions
énergétiques c'est des sujets sur le
canon d'avancer ça faisait partie de la
feuille de route alors
on dit on dit que vous êtes pas beaucoup
de on dit vous savez dans le monde
ministère de l'Agriculture vous vous
pourriez changer je suis très heureux
mystère de l'agriculture d'abord il y a
quelque chose qui est toujours indécent
quand vous êtes ministre de dire vous
pourriez changer vous faire faire part
de de desiderata quelconque c'est le
président de la République la première
ministre le Premier ministre qui décide
c'est la Constitution là aussi c'est la
règle de la 5e République très heureux
ministère de l'Agriculture pourquoi
parce que j'essaie de transformer
l'agriculture de mieux faire comprendre
à nos concitoyens ce qu'ils travaillent
il y a toujours des bons esprits alors
j'adore le sous couvert d'anonymat et
nous sommes beaucoup de ministres avec
beaucoup de sous couverts d'anonymat il
y a toujours des bons esprits qui
ouvrent dans un journal d'un magazine
avec non sourcé non identifié et avec
des qui vous valent bien c'est le
principe de la déco monsieur le ministre
c'est le principe d'un écho et vous
quand vous regarderez
dans les échos en tout cas pour ce qui
est de de comment dirais-je de la
passion que je mets comme vous le voyez
sur les questions agricoles ne croyez
pas l'inverse et par ailleurs je vous
invite à regarder tous les échos qu'on a
commenté parfois dans la vie publique
depuis 10 ans et à quel point que vous
souhaitez est-ce que je suis heureux je
suis heureux à ce poste et je suis
heureux de ce qui ce que j'ai fait mais
je n'ai pas mon destin qui prime et
c'est pas moi qui décide et donc je j'ai
tendance à ne pas répondre à des
questions sur lesquelles je ne décide
pas parce que c'est 20 ça sert à rien
je suis bien dans mes bottes
pour les bottes mais on peut mettre
d'autres d'autres chaussures merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup frère comment on
fait pour manger moins de viande et
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on mange moins de
viande je vous dis ça parce que la Cour
des comptes alors à proposer une
solution radicale pour que la France
tienne ses engagements en matière
climatique elle pense que il faut
baisser les cheptels le nombre de
cheptels bovins qui représente environ
12% de ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre est-ce que cette proposition est
de bonne alloi est-ce qu'elle est
pertinente non mais je vais essayer de
dire quelque chose d'équilibré je l'ai
d'ailleurs dit au Sénat dans une réponse
aux questions gouvernement il faut lire
le rapport de la Cour des comptes parce
que je suis en désaccord il y a que deux
recommandations je suis en désaccord
avec les deux recommandations la
première c'est plutôt d'organiser une
forme de plan social et la deuxième
c'est d'organiser la décapitalisation du
chef peut-être français mais sur le
reste je trouve que ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur de ce document parce qu'il
faut d'abord faut jamais chahuter les
les institutions et l'applique à
moi-même comme ça je peux le dire aux
autres que ça serait mieux qu'il fasse
pareil y compris quand on a des
désaccords mais j'ai un désaccord sur
les recommandations mais il y a un
certain nombre de préconisations sur le
développement des élevages mixtes la
Cour des comptes dit par ailleurs que ce
serait bien que dans certaines zones on
développe plutôt l'élevage pourquoi
parce qu'on a besoin attendez réduire
les cheptel répondez-moi
on a besoin de remettre de l'élevage
dans certaines zones pourquoi parce que
le
l'élevage on en a besoin pour se nourrir
on n'est pas autosuffisant sur aucune
des productions à l'exception du port
donc on peut si jamais on dit je
décapitalise et que la consommation
reste la même c'est l'importation que
vous organisez deuxième élément j'ai
besoin de l'agriculture parce que on a
évoqué on l'a pas évoqué mais il y a un
sujet par un peu tour des haies les S et
la biodiversité les c'est la rétention
d'olée c'est la lutte contre l'érosion
des sols il y a plutôt des haies dans
l'épisode d'élevage donc on a besoin de
la stratégie bas carbone que nous avons
c'est une stratégie de maintien des
prairies alors moi je veux bien qu'on me
dise à Carrefour mais si vous supprimez
l'élevage vous supprimez les prairies et
moi j'ai besoin des éleveurs à la fois
dans leur faction de production pour pas
importer de la viande de l'extérieur ça
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas une tendance
lourde qui est une baisse de
consommation de la viande que deuxième
élément on est en train d'expérimenter
c'est des travaux d'inra et c'est pas
moi qui le dit une alimentation nouvelle
à partir d'algues je rentre pas dans le
détail qui va faire qui dont on dit
l'inrale est assez surprise elle-même de
des résultats qu'on peut baisser de 20
30 % des émissions de méthane en
particulier et donc il faut qu'on
travaille plutôt là-dessus et par
ailleurs on a besoin de décarboner la
fertilisation en bio la fertilisation
des carbonées c'est quoi c'est l'élevage
bon il faut se garder des idées vous
mangez de la viande oui je mange de la
viande
[Musique]
rouge et de la viande
je ne sais pas si c'est le cas
Jean-Claude Tissot merci de nous avoir
rejoint et d'avoir accepté monsieur le
ministre et monsieur le sénateur
socialiste de la loi le principe du
débat on va revenir sur deux sujets
qu'on a un peu abordés et d'abord on
commence par les pesticides monsieur
Tissot alors c'est à vous alors merci de
votre invitation merci monsieur le
ministre et je suis très heureux d'être
face à face moi aussi parce que on a
échangé longtemps longuement durant le
les semaines dernière au Sénat mais
c'était compliqué nous nous nos échanges
en tout cas vous laisser échange je
crois qu'on a eu des changements
de vous dire quand même monsieur le
ministre et vous avez parlé dans la
première partie de l'émission vous avez
parlé de responsabilité moi je vais en
appeler à votre responsabilité parce que
bouteille quand même un discours assez
paradoxal quand on parle de produits
phytosanitaires fin 2022 devant la
commission des affaires économiques dont
je fais partie au Sénat vous aviez tenu
un discours plutôt ambitieux et j'étais
plutôt satisfait du propos que vous
pouvez tenir et puis notamment sur les
néonicotinoïdes un sujet sur lequel je
me suis beaucoup battu et avant de
devenir bien moins dix ans sur en cette
année 2023 notamment avec la fosse fine
elle doit se mettre à clore mais mettons
la chlore et comme vous le savez je suis
un ancien agriculteur je vais donc pas
tenir un discours caricatural mais je
pense être assez légitime pour tenir un
tel propos moi il y a eu deux plans et
confitaux les confitaux 1 les confitours
2 on a dépensé 700 millions d'euros
quels sont les résultats vous venez
d'annoncer un plan écofyto 3 et donc ma
question elle va être très simple qu'y
a-t-il dans ce plan Écophyto 3 qui va
pouvoir inverser la tendance parce qu'en
parle de pesticides certes on parle on
pense à l'agriculture mais vous pensez
aussi
à tous tous les dégâts collatéraux des
pesticides c'est-à-dire essentiellement
alors pardon parce que c'est un faut pas
que ce soit non plus un échange de
d'initier inversé la tendance pour que
l'usage et le recours aux pesticides
soient infiniment moins important dans
l'agriculture française donc c'est votre
question et on écoute la réponse
aujourd'hui on est quand même 32 %
au-dessus de la moyenne européenne pour
la consommation française de pesticides
alors c'est une mauvaise note alors
est-ce que d'abord je peux je peux deux
secondes sur phosphine et s metola
chlore qu'on soit au clair parce que
alors ce sont deux pesticides
l'autre est un herbicide l'inverse
désherber l'autre sert sur la fausse
fine c'est un sujet très simple c'est
une molécule qui est interdite sur
l'espace européen qui est autorisé en
revanche en dérogation pour les pays qui
sont importateurs de céréales
au sud de la Méditerranée par exemple
qui demande sof à ne pas pouvoir
importer chez eux exporter chez eux de
la fausse fine tous les pays d'Europe
actif cela il m'a semblé qu'en
conscience dans le moment de crise qu'on
traverse avec une crise alimentaire
mondiale avec un problème de sécurité
alimentaire je considère que dans
l'urgence dans laquelle nous sommes et
comme c'est une demande des pays
d'accueil de ces céréales pourquoi ils
veulent de la fausse fine parce qu'ils
veulent pas que des insectes venant de
chez nous viennent sur leur territoire
c'est aussi simple que ça et donc c'est
leur préconisations qu'on applique et
donc ce qu'on trouve un jour des
alternatives j'ai aucune difficulté avec
ça mais
ça dépend des produits ça dépend des
produits mais sur les il y a des sujets
qui sont plus simples c'est plus
compliqué reconnaissant le sur des
herbicides que sur d'autres produits
mais je n'en rabats pas sur la volonté
mais je n'en rabatterai jamais sur
l'idée que quand même si jamais on peut
pas nourrir ces pays-là c'est d'autres
qui le feront en particulier monsieur
Poutine et je pense qu'on partagera ce
point de vue et que donc en conscience
on a besoin de le faire et sur le S
métaux la classe chose que j'ai demandé
j'ai pas remis en cause
jamais l'analyse scientifique j'ai juste
dit que ça serait jamais vous ne me
verrez je dis ça je vous assure
croyez-moi
on va pas se faire un concours de bonne
voie je crois qu'on est plutôt sincère
dans nos expressions sur le S métaux la
chlore le sujet c'était de dire est-ce
qu'on peut pas le synchroniser avec le
calendrier européen voilà il va y avoir
bientôt une décision européenne je
trouvais que c'était c'était pas
indécent de dire ça parce que ce qu'on
interdit chez nous on peut pas
l'interdire de produits venant
d'Allemagne d'Italie ou d'Espagne donc
c'est vin ce qu'on fait si jamais on
fait des choses on n'arrive pas à monter
les sujets au niveau européen et y
compris par exemple sur un certain
nombre de réglementations européennes je
suis pour qu'on ait une réglementation
européenne et qu'elle soit
éventuellement plus ambitieuse mais
qu'elle soit au niveau européen sinon
c'est la France qui perd et vous l'avez
vu en attendant
c'est quelque chose qui est né du
Grenelle de l'environnement ça fait donc
bientôt
là aussi je disais sur un autre sujet
tout à l'heure reconnaissons qu'on n'est
pas au rendez-vous de la promesse
collective que nous avions formulé mais
tout le monde doit prendre sa part dans
son exercice j'ai pas dit que vous la
prenez pas mais je suis comptable de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et chacun doit
dire que pourquoi on a été en situation
d'échec pour deux sujets on n'a pas mis
d'argent sur la recherche et dans le
plan France 2030 on met plus d'un
milliard d'euros sur la recherche parce
que la seule solution c'est de trouver
des alternatives mais alors pourquoi
partage carrément mais sauf que chaque
loi de finance mais là on les a la
recherche sur la recherche le budget de
l'inrae est quand même quatre fois moins
alors
que le budget de recherche de Bayer vous
irez demander vous irez vous irez
demander à l'inrae s'il pense
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas fait un saut
quantitatif et donc avec derrière un
saut qualitatif sur les moyens de la
recherche mais ce retard là ça fait 20
ans qu'on l'accumule je prends l'exemple
de de néonicotinoïde puisque vous étiez
sénateur et vous aviez vous aviez refusé
la dérogation supplémentaire on vote
cette loi là en 2014 si j'ai bonne
mémoire
d'interdiction des néonicotines en
France on a mis quasiment aucun moyen
sur la recherche pendant 5 ou 6 ans et
donc on s'est retrouvé je fais griller à
faire personne c'est la situation dont
on a l'impression et donc on a besoin
pour faire quelque chose qui marche
mieux dans ecophytos de mettre les
moyens sur la recherche et la recherche
d'alternative et de poser les choses en
termes de planification et moi j'ai
demandé c'est ce qu'avait dit la
première ministre ou quoi si on
l'agriculture je veux qu'on sorte toutes
les molécules quels sont les risques qui
sont associés quels sont les
alternatives qu'on a quels sont les
impasses qu'on a et qu'est-ce qu'on
cherche pour essayer de sortir de ce que
vous êtes convaincus parce que ce que
disait monsieur Tissot dans le fond
c'est qu'il y a toujours des bonnes
raisons pour ne pas faire voilà c'est ça
vraiment productive efficace je doute
pas votre sincérité mais en fait vous
essayez de trouver une solution sans
changer de modèle et aujourd'hui force
est de constater qu'on est au bout du
bout du modèle on est au bout du modèle
complètement chimique un modèle qui a
sorti la France de l'ornière a sorti de
la guerre
14-45 bien évidemment il fallait nourrir
voilà vous connaissent tout ce qu'il
soit mais aujourd'hui on est plus dans
ce modèle là et aujourd'hui moi ce qu'on
peut vous reprocher et peut-être que
dans le plan économie GG il faudra voir
de quelle manière ça peut s'organiser
sur les années qui arrivent mais en tout
cas il faut absolument encourager et
vous parliez du bio tout à l'heure il
faut encourager une agriculture
alternative et une agriculture
alternative permettez-moi juste de vous
dire que c'est vous avez tenu ses
propres là c'est pas obligatoirement
être amis c'est pas obligatoirement être
Emmanuel Macron c'est pas oui pardon
c'est le sujet
réfléchir autrement mais être sur la
sobriété c'est pas obligatoirement être
un décroissant ça veut dire on réfléchit
autrement et on réfléchit à la manière
dont on pourrait se passer des produits
phytos ça veut dire quoi vous parliez
tout à l'heure des insecticides des
herbicides mais on peut s'en passer des
herbicides on peut c'est une autre façon
culturelle c'est-à-dire quoi des
rotations culturelles différentes du nom
labour il y a plein de solutions
techniques et on sait que c'est une
solution aujourd'hui existent et marche
sauf que et là pour le coup je vais
peut-être être un petit peu dynés
une force un lobby très très fort dans
l'agriculture en amont sur la lavance
les fournisseurs les les semenciers les
les les les bailleurs compagnie et
confrères qui qui qui qui qui
fournissent tous ces produits chimiques
moi je voudrais pas que vous cédiez aux
siret de ces gens-là
ce modèle alternatif mais je suis
d'accord avec l'idée qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de faire évoluer le modèle je dis
simplement j'avais encore quelques jours
les producteurs de cerises on a interdit
des molécules dis mais toi oui et on a
eu raison d'interdire le dimensions pas
sur un autre chemin simplement
aujourd'hui on est en impasse technique
voilà donc on a 30 à 40% des rectangles
il y a pas d'alternative sinon changer
de modèle et on n'a pas besoin de
produits alternatif non mais il faut
qu'on trouve si on a besoin de produits
par exemple sur la cerise un dispositif
qui s'appelle l'insecte stérile c'est un
truc tout à fait c'est du ce qu'on
appelle du biocontrôle mais si le sujet
c'est de revenir à un moment où on peut
avoir ce qui a été avant la guerre de 40
et bien avant c'est-à-dire des crises de
maladies des crises d'insectes qui fasse
qu'on fasse disparaître les récoltes
qu'est-ce qu'on a gagné on a rien gagné
donc on a besoin de changer de faire
évoluer le modèle mais on a besoin de le
faire pour continuer va pouvoir produire
parce que qu’est-ce qui se passe en
France par exemple sur les fruits et
légumes on était autosuffisant il y a 20
ans résultat des courses on est à 50 %
d'autosuffisance qu'est-ce que je gagne
si je peux plus produire de cerises donc
j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de ça c'est pas
faux oui c'est pas faux le constat
évidemment je parle je le constat mais
c'est pas parce qu'on utilise moins de
pesticides ou plus de pesticides qu'on a
qu'on produit moins de légumes c'est pas
du tout le problème
mais je n'ai pas dit que c'était que ça
mais je dis ça fait partie des facteurs
et je ne dis pas Ray homologuant des
pesticides qui ont été interdits je dis
juste il faut trouver des solutions
alternatives parce que si la seule
perspective que je donne un producteur
de cerise c'est tous les ans d'être
indemnisés de la perte parce que elle a
drosophile qui attaqué ses cerises il
arrêtera de produire des cerises parce
que les agriculteurs les arboriculteurs
et les autres ils ont pas envie de
produire pour perdre parce que c'est du
gaspillage ça c'est ce qu'on appelle du
gaspillage alimentaire n'est pas une
solution vous savez que le principal
gaspillage alimentaire il n'est pas dans
nos frigo le principal gaspillage
alimentaire c'est les récoltes qu'on
perd
vous posez monsieur chemise mais
vraiment fondamental aujourd'hui si on
part du principe ou le lot est un bien
commun de l'humanité et je pense qu'on
est tous d'accord pour pour dire ça et
d'autres personnes l'ont dit bien avant
nous comment peut-on se résoudre à
accepter que que quelques-uns puissent
subtiliser
ce bien commun sans se poser la question
qui est fondamentale comment c'est
quelques personnes rendent à l'humanité
alors quelques-uns je veux dire prendre
l'exemple de sainte Soline c'est pas
pour polémiquer mais parce que tout le
monde connaît bien ce problème là
on fait une grande bassine on pompe dans
la nappe phréatique on remplit cette
grande bassine qui va servir qu'à
quelques-uns c'est-à-dire qu'à quelques
producteurs et et on prend un bien
commun comment ce bien commun on le rend
et je m'adresse
une question
alors je réponds d'abord quand vous
prélevez de l'eau en l'agriculture c'est
vous le savez parce que vous êtes du
métier vous prélevez pas de l'eau pour
remplir votre piscine ou nettoyer votre
d'accord bien sûr
produire un bien commun parce que
l'alimentation c'est un bien commun
quand vous prenez de l'eau quand vous
prenez de l'eau pour arroser des tomates
non mais de la du maïs qui peut servir à
l'alimentation animale vous prenez de
l'eau pour le bien commun qui est
alimentaire alors quelle est la question
qui a derrière sur lequel je peux
partager et je vais reprendre l'exemple
de sainte-soly parce que c'est un bon
exemple ou un exemple de mauvaise
polémique sainte-solide c'était 21
millions de mètres cubes prélevés tous
les étés le modèle qui a été construit
avec beaucoup plus d'agriculteurs
d'ailleurs qui sont engagés c'est des
centaines d'agriculteurs même si
d'autres mais pour des raisons
topographiques ils ont moins accès c'est
à la fin 13 millions qui seront prélevés
dont si seulement on était donc on va
passer de 20 millions de mètres cubes
prélevés l'été à 6 millions de mètres
cubes donc il y a un effort de fait ça
veut dire que le projet était pas si
bien mais si le projet est bien
puisqu'on va réduire la consommation au
départ et deuxième élément oui mais
maintenant il est signé il y a un
protocole tout le monde était d'accord
et donc il faut avancer et les
agriculteurs ils sont engagés sur quoi
sur une modification de la seulement sur
une réduction l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires et ça pourrait être
contrôlé et sur la plantation de haie et
donc si le seul perspective que vous
donnez au monde agricole c'est
débrouillez vous sans eau ah non j'ai
jamais dit ça
c'est tragique et donc il y a des
endroits où c'est des réserves de
subtilités
qui s'imposent aucune plante ne pousse
sans eau nous sommes dans les tomates
pouvaient pousser sans eau je pense dans
la vraie vie on est bien d'accord il
faut de la pierre et de l'eau voilà
voilà donc après pour revenir
à la problématique du stockage de l'eau
alors il y a les solutions des retenues
colinéaires etc mais il faut quand même
juste savoir que quand on retient 100 on
a 100 qui se disparaît on a dès qu'on
extrait de l'eau du sol et qu'on le met
dans une bassine on a 30 % des
performances et à nouveau votre question
parce qu'on arrive à la fin monsieur
Tissot et à nouveau quand on asperge on
on on irrigue on repère au niveau de
l'eau donc ma question est très claire
comment faites-vous pour encourager et
comment vous aider finalement c'est ça
financièrement vous encourager des
systèmes alternatifs du goutte-à-goutte
et seulement et seulement aux
productions qui apportent une plus-value
parce que si c'est pour un rosier de
l'herbe qui qu'on va donner à des vaches
que ces vaches vont faire du lait qu'on
va le lait à 350 euros la tonne ça ne
sert à rien de réponse en deux minutes
si c'est possible pas de souci comme on
fait ou Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale
simplement je partage l'idée que c'est
on doit le gérer en commun cette affaire
là c'est à dire que c'est pas l'affaire
des uns c'est pas l'affaire de ceux qui
pour le tourisme s'en occupe de ceux qui
en ont besoin pour l'industrie donc on a
besoin de réfléchir en commun je suis
d'ailleurs assez favorable à vous c'est
possible c'est pas c'est pas le cas dans
les à sainte-soulines mais d'avoir des
ouvrages qui soient multi-usages qui
puissent servir l'alimentation en
octobre le meilleur exemple c'est
serre-ponçons bien sûr mais serpent sont
aujourd'hui les détracteurs que vous
avez là sur la table ils refuserait
Serre-Ponçon la vérité c'est ça mais oui
il vous dirait que on vient parce qu'on
est sur un cours d'eau c'est un poisson
or Serre-Ponçon c'est un modèle qui
marche y compris en partage et donc on a
besoin simplement de dire aux
agriculteurs voilà ce qu'on les ouvrages
qu'on vous autorise mais c'est
simplement ça se fait dans le cadre
d'une transition du modèle
y compris pour dire c'est plutôt cette
culture qui est priorisée y compris sur
les efforts de réduction des produits
phytosanitaires y compris ce qu'on a
fait sur Samsung et donc faut plutôt
encourager la transition l'accès à l'eau
il doit être comment dirais-je organiser
pour faire en sorte qu'il permette la
transition et pas qu'il accélère des
processus de
pression sur l'eau qui soit trop fort
vous voyez bien qu'il y a des modèles on
voit bien qu'il y a des modèles dans
certains pays du monde compris en Europe
où on a trop prélevé d'eau et le système
s'effondre c'est pas le modèle qu'on a
en France et donc c'est celui-là qu'on
doit privilégier et de ce point de vue
là on a une gestion collective et
commune c'est à dire le penser que c'est
pour tout le monde qu'on le fait y
compris en terme d'alimentation oui ou
non non en suivant en tout cas c'était
passionnant merci beaucoup on est prêt
ça avance merci mais restez avec nous on
va écouter maintenant Vincent roux qu'on
retrouve au feyrolive Vincent quel est
votre question au ministre
oui bonjour rebonsoir Marcelo il y a une
affaire qui a pas mal émue ce week-end
c'est l'agression d'un petit garçon qui
s'appelle Kenzo 8 ans c'était lors d'un
match en marche d'un match Ajaccio om ou
des des supporters des hooligans se sont
introduits dans sa loge on frappait son
père et on agressé également cet enfant
qui est handicapé ce soir Emmanuel
Macron a dit au Mont-Saint-Michel qui
voulait des sanctions claires et fortes
on en attendait pas moins mais est-ce
que vous pensez que ce genre de de
discours suffit à arrêter cette ce ces
violences est-ce qu'il faut pas des
mesures vraiment plus radicales des
mesures d'interdiction de stade
notamment pour un certain nombre de
supporters et de d'afficionados mais
enfin les mesures de l'interdiction
seront produites dès lors qu'on va
identifier les enfin je crois qu'ils
sont en cours d'identification les
coupables de ces actes donc ça c'est une
chose l'interdiction ça d'être une
mesure la justice doit passer parce que
il y a quelque chose de très choquant
dans ce genre d'attitude et puis quand
vous réfléchissez à ce que c'est l'acte
de quelqu'un qui ne savait peut-être pas
que cet enfant par ailleurs était malade
souffrait d'un cancer du cerveau était
venu au fond exprimer son soutien à son
club
privé un enfant de la joie de défendre
son club il faut quand même avoir un
drôle d'esprit et c'est là qu'on a
quelque chose à faire collectivement
pour que partout on dénonce la violence
parce qu'on a eu en bord de stade aussi
ailleurs insupportun qui s'est permis
d'agresser un joueur pourquoi parce
qu'il avait marqué un but on est quelque
chose de l'ordre de la violence qui
s'exprime c'était entre Bordeaux et
Rodez si j'abonne mémoire on a quelque
chose qui n'est inacceptable mais pas
que dans le sport partout la violence
n'est pas un moyen d'expression et la
violence verbale précède la violence
physique et donc j'espère que les
personnes qui sont coupables de cet acte
seront condamnés parce que au fond cet
enfant et ses parents étaient agressés
simplement parce qu'il venait supporter
un club c'est quand même dément d'un
point de vue de la de l'esprit public
maintenant qu'on a besoin de travailler
là-dessus et de dénoncer sans relâche
ces éléments là merci beaucoup d'avoir
posé cette question Vincent qui nous
renvoie à l'ensemble des violences avec
une espèce de loi des séries ces
dernières semaines qui est tout à fait
stupéfiante et sidérante et qui nous
interpelle tous Merci à vous monsieur le
ministre d'avoir été l'invité ce soir
merci Monsieur Tissot encore une fois
d'avoir accepté le principe du débat
c'était très intéressant on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine à 19h30 pour
audition publique bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]